[Music]  i'm john roberts and i've been with fox  news for 10 years one of the first  stories that i covered when i got to fox  news was the increasing  number of suicides among military  members and i met this fella and his  wife he was the grandfather of a young  marine who died by suicide and he was a  drill sergeant when he was in the  military so here's a tough little guy  who's used to telling the troops what to  do and cracking the whip and he  literally came apart during the  interview he could not stop weeping for  the loss of his grandson and that's  probably one of the most moving moments  i've ever experienced as a journalist  i've really learned at fox sort of a  different perspective on journalism it's  not just telling somebody's story it's  about getting involved in somebody's  story it's about caring  for that person  and i think our audience appreciates  that